c'est également l'un des résultats les
plus attendus de la soirée celui de la
ville de pau françois bayrou jouait son
va tout le président du modem s'incline
avec moins de 400 voix d'écart devant la
candidate socialiste martine lignières
cassou françois bayrou qui fuyaient la
presse aujourd'hui a finalement accepté
de recevoir l'une de nos équipes dans sa
maison à bordères ni remords ni regrets
le patron du modem garde le cap santé
drigo emilie keno jean-michel mire c'est
ici dans sa maison des pyrénées
atlantiques qu'il avait décidé de se
reposer toute la journée avec ses
chevaux loin des caméras
finalement françois bayrou accepte de
répondre à quelques journalistes le
besoin de répéter une fois encore qu'il
ne regrette rien surtout pas la
stratégie d'indépendance du modem tout
le monde a compris que pour la première
fois en france il y avait un parti
capable de parler avec les deux autres
et pas seulement d'être ficelé dans
l'alliance avec et c'est une novation
assez importante que vous ayez passé des
heures et des heures et des heures et
des heures
on parle alors évidemment toutes les
forces qui veulent que rien ne change se
liguent pour expliquer que c'est pas
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut faire et
bien valeur montre et pourtant pour
l'instant cette stratégie vie coûte très
cher d'abord la mairie de pau où il a
été battu à 340 voix près ailleurs son
parti se retrouve avec très peu d'élus
arbitre de l'entre-deux tours
le modem doit repartir à zéro la
conséquence d'une ligne illisible pour
le parti socialiste le modem est victime
de son absence de stratégie nationale il
n'a pas pu clarifier ses positions si
bien qu' il n'a pas été en mesure de
peser sur les choix
une situation qui aiguise déjà les
appétits ceux d'hervé morin notamment
l'ancien ami qui rêve aujourd'hui de
dépecer le modem
je dis à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
sont de sensibilité de centre et de
centre-droit et qui refusent l'idée que
le centrisme doit sombré au même en même
temps et dans le même vous
que dans la démarche d'isolement dans
laquelle est rentré françois bayrou je
leur dis revenez venez nous rejoindre
même au sein du modem des élus dénoncent
une stratégie suicidaire
impossible de savoir si françois bayrou
pourra tenir jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle de 2012
la seule qui compte vraiment pour mieux